bonjour à tous donc aujourd'hui un petit
tuto assez rapide pour vous apprendre à
identifier les causes et les
conséquences d'un phénomène
ça peut paraître évident pour des élèves
de 5e faut savoir que l'identification
de cause et de conséquence n'est pas
possible pour une question de structure
mentale avant l'âge de 15 16 ans
normalement vous êtes dans la bonne
fourchette et pour vous savez ça ne
devrait pas poser de problème alors une
cause au niveau des définitions bas une
cause c'est ce qui produit un effet une
conséquence c est ce qui fait suite à
une action à un phénomène
si je prends un exemple le cas d'une
casserole avec de l'eau qui vous quelle
est la cause de l'évaporation de l'eau
c'est l'élévation de la chaleur
l'élévation chaleur et bien ceux qui
causent l'évaporation
on ne peut pas imputer l'évaporation un
autre phénomène
quelle est la conséquence de cette
évaporation mais c'est que si je laisse
ma casserole sur le feu ou de quelques
quelques minutes le récipient sera vite
c'est le fait que le récipient soit vite
et bien conséquence de l'avant port à
sion
non vraiment cette articulation très
clair qui se fait entre ces différents
éléments
provoc c'est ce qui est antérieur ce qui
se passe avant qui est le motif de qui
est à l'origine de et il ya bien un lien
envoyé un véritable vérifiables entre
cette cause et l'action l'événement le
fait qu'ils se produit par rapport à
celle ci une conséquence quant à elle
c'est un petit peu l' inverse puisque
l'accord la conséquence est provoqué par
est postérieure se passe après et
l'effet 2 et a également un lien
vérifiable avec l'action l'événement où
le fait qui est la cause ducept
conséquences
il ne faut pas confondre corrélation
alors la corrélation c'est le lien entre
deux variables
j'ai quelque chose qui augmente l'autre
chose au monde
si le nombre de chauffeurs qui
conduisent en état d'ébriété augmente le
nombre d'accidents augmente là il ya
bien une corrélation qui était aussi ici
noirs cassis une causalité
mais cette corrélation n'est pas
toujours une causalité
c'est un qui varie en même temps que ses
deux mais il ne faudrait pas croire que
c'est un essai du hong son causes et
conséquences
c'est un essai et deux en fait sont deux
conséquences d'une même cause de à
et donc forcément quand à apparaît
j'obtiens c1 je tiens ces deux donc c1
et c2 finalement varie en même temps il
y avait une corrélation entre les dieux
mais pas une causalité puisque la
causalité se fait par rapport à à à et
la cause de ces dieux et là il ya
causalité et non plus une simple
corrélation
prenons un exemple qui est un classique
conscience sociale point que les élèves
de 6e primaire est grande
au mieux ils lisent il y a juste une
corrélation dans ce cas-ci entre la
pointure et la lecture mais pas de
causalité en effet c'est pas parce que
j'ai les grands pieds que je vais bien
lire la causalité à les situer ailleurs
la pointure et la capacité de lecture en
fête ont une cause commune qui est l'âge
enfin je vous propose un petit exercice
rapide ici pour vous aider à vous y
faire avec cette ses causes et ses
conséquences
alors je vous demandais d'identifier les
causes et conséquences de l'extension
des surfaces cultivées et des pâturages
au sud ou au nord du sahara
je vous laisse lire texte fait
éventuellement une pause identifié cette
cause ou ses causes et cette conséquence
ou ses conséquences
et puis appuyez sur play pour obtenir un
correctif le correctif
le voici s'il est impossible pour le
moment de savoir si nous entrons dans
une farce une phase d'une phase pardon
de forte sécheresse au sud ou au nord du
sahara il est en revanche évident que
l'accroissement du nombre de personnes
qui entraîne l'extension des surfaces
cultivées celle des pâturages provoque
également une très grave
sur des sols donc ici le terme le
phénomène qui est à expliquer c'est
l'extension des surfaces cultivées les
pâturages d'où est-ce que ça provient
baisse et l'accroissement du nombre des
hommes la pression démographique tout
simplement qui est la cause de cette
extension des surfaces cultivées des
pâturages et qu'est ce que cela a comme
conséquence c'est une grave dégradation
des sols qui sont soumis à une plus
forte pression